Let's go next to our caller from the seven
to four area code who's calling today from
seven to four.
Hello, David.
Yeah, who is this?
This is Karlo from P.A. 16 District LAAM here.
We had we have a terribly sorry.
We have a terrible congressman.
His name is Mike Kelly.
Right.
And I feel like people really underestimate
the importance of local elections.
I think, you know, people focus way too much
on like who's going to be the president.
But, you know, people don't really see the
importance and the value of people who are
representing, you know, their local communities.
I think that you are right in that people
tend to, particularly in the space of political
hobby ism and infotainment, people tend to
spend a lot more time following political
issues that may never affect them directly
or will only affect them directly in limited
ways while ignoring the local issues.
And I by no means am suggesting anybody ignore
who is their senator, who is the president.
But I think the right advice is understand
that your day to day is going to be affected
by your city councilor if you have a city
councilor, the mayor of wherever you live,
etc. and we want to make sure that people
understand that.
And Republicans do understand that.
That's the crazy thing.
They don't necessarily make a big deal out
of promoting it.
They very quietly take over school boards
and city councils and they get it.
And we need to get it as well.
Right.
And here, I mean, it's a pretty conservative
area.
But we do have someone who is running against
Mike Kelly.
Her name is Christy Canibus.
That's Jenn.
I beat us.
And I'm I'm just here to reach out to people,
your audience that, you know, get her name
out there.
Please donate to her campaign, because here
I mean, Mike Kelly has a horrible track record,
horrible voting record.
He voted against the like every health care
bill during this pandemic.
He voted against and he voted against the
George FOID Justice and Policing Act as well.
Which just unacceptable.
His voting record.
He's voted alongside Trump consistently.
So the plan is to get rid of them.
So I would just like to get Christie's name
out there.
All right.
Well, people said I am not familiar with her,
but I will look into it.
And I appreciate you bringing it up.
Right.
The A16 district.
Thank you, David.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.
Yes, many, many races to get involved in.
Let's go to our caller from the four zero
seven area code.
Who's calling today from four zero seven?
With me, Mr. Pacman.
Yes.
Who's this?
My name is William.
I'm calling from Florida seven.
Love it.
Anyways, I had a kind of a my specific question.
I feel a lot of a lot of my discussions with
more right, weaning people or just maybe even
center or even center left.
They have a specific sort of commitment to
capitalism because they sort of.
Which McCollom have a conflation with market.
For whatever reason, they associate the idea
of capitalism equaling markets when they're
not necessarily the same thing.
Do you feel like that's a big reason as to
why people are so adamant in your own interactions
with right wingers as to why they don't want
to change that sort of a market system?
In other words, that people might like markets
and they mistakenly believe that only in capitalism
do markets exist.
And thus they, yeah, they need to support
capitalism when you could, for example, support
something like market socialism.
Exactly.
Yeah, I myself, I would I think that there's
no doubt that, you know, the average the average
person probably is not super informed about
a concept like market socialism.
I actually do think that most people, if presented
with the basic framework of market socialism,
which would be socialized ownership, but markets
still exist.
I think a lot of people may not know about
it, but if they did, they still wouldn't be
for it.
But I think that we would only know that if
people were aware of it and many people are
not.
So I don't think your comment is without merit.
Well, but that's really the only question
I had.
Thank you for your time.
All right.
Thank you.
And please call me David.
We don't need to be so formal on this program.